-After the Electoral College
made it official on Monday,
some Republicans
are now finally admitting
that Joe Biden will be
the next president
and many in the GOP
and right-wing media
are still insisting
there is a way
for Trump to subvert
the will of the voters
and remain in office.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Been a tough week
for Donald Trump.
The Electoral College made
Joe Biden's win official;
Republican leaders began
to finally admit
that Biden will be
the next president,
albeit way too late;
a judge ruled
that Trump's business
must turn over documents sought
as part of an investigation
by the New York
Attorney General's Office;
and, on top of all that,
Trump's neighbors in Florida
went public
with a small request --
Please do not move here.
-Trump's neighbors in Florida
are bracing for the possibility
he just might spend
his post-White House days
right there alongside them.
Tonight, The Washington Post
is reporting
that some of the neighbors
down in Mar-a-Lago
want the city of Palm Beach
to prevent Trump
from settling down there.
They argue he signed away
his legal right
to live there full-time
back in the '90s,
when the resort was
originally converted
from a private residence
to a private club.
-Just amazing. New Yorkers
don't want him in New York.
His neighbors don't want him
at Mar-a-Lago.
This is like one of those
ironic punishments
for a racist
on "The Twilight Zone."
"We do have a hacienda
available in Mexico City."
[ As Trump ]
No!
He's going to be our first
nomad ex-president.
Remember how everyone made fun
of Hillary Clinton
for taking a walk in the woods,
once, after she lost?
Trump's going to have
to live in the woods.
Years from now,
a group of hikers
are going to find him holed up
in a cave, with a long beard,
doing rallies for a bunch
of polecats.
[ As Trump ]
We love the ferrets,
don't we, folks?
Natural allies.
But the skunks,
how do we feel about the skunks?
Not nice.
Not nice, the skunks.
Trump's ego has obviously
taking a hit this week,
so his allies have come up
with an idea
to make him feel better --
give him credit
for the COVID vaccine
he had nothing to do with.
Several Fox hosts have suggested
that it should be called
the Trump vaccine,
and a right-wing columnist
from The Washington Post
wrote an op-ed called...
First of all, why should Trump
get credit for the vaccine?
What did he do, besides say
we should make a vaccine?
I mean, I think we should make
dinner for the kids every night,
but I'm smart enough not
to tell my wife
we should call it Dad Spaghetti.
Also, you're never going
to unite this country,
and it's crazy to try.
Biden should give
the same speech
my algebra teacher used to give
on the first
nice Friday in April.
"I don't want to be here.
You don't want to be here.
Let's just get through this crap
so we can all go home."
Trump didn't do anything.
He's like the guy standing
on the sidewalk,
watching you parallel park.
"You got to cut
the wheels, man."
Yeah, I know that!
For a crowd that constantly
claims your feelings
don't matter,
they seem to think
Donald Trump's feelings
matter a lot,
and especially this week,
after the Electoral College,
yet again,
confirmed that Trump had lost.
Yesterday at a rally in Georgia,
Biden joked about the fact
that multiple recounts
in the Electoral College have
confirmed his victory there.
-Thank you for standing strong
to make sure
your voices were heard,
your votes were counted,
and counted,
and counted again!
[ Laughter ]
I'm starting to feel like
I won Georgia three times.
-It's true.
Biden's win in Georgia
has been confirmed three times.
And, in terms of convincing
someone of the truth,
needing three times
is what's known as a Scrooging.
But there you have it,
three times.
Biden's win in Georgia
has been confirmed more times
than a dentist appointment.
And, Dr. Giotopoulos,
you don't need
to call me every day
for three weeks
before the appointment.
Just send me one email,
two days ahead of time,
so I know it's time
to start flossing.
And, yes, I've been
wearing my retainer.
[ Hushed ]
Honey, have you seen
my retainer?
Also, if Biden's Georgia win
has been confirmed three times,
that means Trump's loss has also
been confirmed three times.
When you get rejected,
it's pretty pathetic
to double-check once,
let alone three times.
Trump has been
outside Georgia's window,
holding the boom box
three nights in a row
and, each night,
Georgia shut the window
and turned on the sprinklers.
And that may seem like a dated
movie reference, but remember,
Trump's only political
philosophy is "Say Anything."
Only a true business genius
like Trump
could parlay
one embarrassing loss
into multiple
embarrassing losses.
It's like investing in Enron
and then, when it goes bust,
you jump out the window,
but, instead of the sidewalk,
you land on a couch
someone was throwing out
and you fart super loud,
just as a dowager countess
is getting out of a town car.
Trump found a way
to keep reminding people,
on a nearly daily basis,
that he's now the only
president in history
to lose the popular vote,
get impeached,
then lose reelection, which is
worse than being forgotten.
Zachary Taylor sucked, too,
but nobody even remembers
that guy,
except that he's the only
president in history
named after two
[bleep] toddlers.
Zachary!
Put that stick --
Because I said so!
Taylor!
Where are your pants?
You don't know?
Zachary!
Why is your stick bigger?!
[ Growling ] You two!
[ Laughter ]
On the plus side for Trump,
he's the president
every kid for the next 100 years
is going to want to do
their oral report on.
Jason, your president is
James K. Polk.
[ As Andy Samberg ]
I don't want that snoozefest!
I want the guy
who knew Grimace!
[ Laughing ] Samberg.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Samberg ]
I wanna do the
Grimace president!
Nobody here gets me!
[ Laughter ]
And, yet, the deluded Trump
dead-enders will not give up,
not because they genuinely think
there's a path
to staying in power,
but because they're fully
invested in the belief
that their opponents
are illegitimate
and any votes for Democrats
are fraudulent.
On Monday, after the
Electoral College vote,
the far-right network Newsmax
tried to brush it off
like it was some
inconsequential technicality.
-There are people, right now,
who are out there,
calling Joe Biden
the president-elect.
Now, at this point,
there is some political
and some historical
justification
for them to do so,
at this point.
I personally feel they're wrong.
-Oh, you personally feel
they're wrong?
You don't want
your controversial views
to stain the sterling
journalistic reputation
of Newsmax, which,
up until recently,
got less attention
than a stand-up comic
opening at Ozzfest.
"How's everybody doing?!
You guys ready to thrash?!
First, first, that's great.
Where are my married guys at?
[ Laughter ]
Married guys?"
I don't know much about Newsmax,
but it sounds like the name
of one of those fake news shows
that's really just a late night
infomercial for hair plugs.
"Welcome back to Newsmax.
Our next guest is
the medical genius
behind the latest breakthrough
in hair science,
known as paint."
But, hey, he personally
feels they're wrong
to call Joe Biden
the president-elect,
just like I personally feel
that the 2007 Academy Awards
were wrong to give Best Actor
to Forest Whitaker
for "The Last King of Scotland,"
instead of me, for my role
in" American Dreamz,"
with Hugh Grant,
who said, to my face,
about my performance --
and this is real --
"I don't remember it."
We had scenes together.
[ Laughter ]
The Trump cabal is so committed
to subverting democracy
and painting Biden's win
as illegitimate
that some states even held
fake Electoral College votes
and pretended an alternate
slate of electors
would be sent to Congress
to put Trump over the top
once they, you know,
finally win a court case.
As we speak today,
an alternate slate of electors
in the contested states
is going to vote
and we're going to send
those results up to Congress.
This will ensure that all of our
legal remedies remain open.
-Alternate electors?
You might be thinking
of an alternate universe.
"Not only is the president
well on his way
to reelection here on Earth-C,
he is also one step closer
to apprehending America's
gravest threat,
Superman,
the villain of Krypton."
And I'm sorry, but none of your
legal remedies remain open.
You guys lost
almost 60 court cases,
including two
at the Supreme Court.
At this point, you're the kid
at the spelling bee
who's buying time
by continuing to list letters.
"We're going to stop
you there, Kyle.
Pheromone doesn't start
with an "F,"
and I think we both know
it doesn't have 35 E's."
And, no, you didn't just lose
on a technicality,
as Trump and his allies
have continued to claim.
-They're winning these things
on little technicalities,
like a thing called standing.
-Standing is not a technicality.
It means you don't even
have the right
to bring the case.
That's like saying --
[ As Trump ]
They won't let me play
Little League
because of the technicality
that I'm not nine years old.
Though I do you think
it's worth pausing,
while we're putting
so much emphasis
on the Electoral College,
to remind everyone
that the Electoral College
is a terrible system
and the way you can tell
it's a bad system
is the majority of Americans
want to get rid of it.
And it felt that way
for decades,
but it's still there.
If you're a sane, normal person,
you might have assumed that the
presidential election was over
the moment it became clear
that Joe Biden would get
more votes than Donald Trump.
That's how it works
in most democracies,
with the exception of Norway,
of course,
where the prime minister
is chosen
by a mystical gnome named Lars,
who emerges from his cave
once every four years
and names a new leader,
in exchange for fish balls
and orange soda.
And that's today's...
[ Shimmering tune plays ]
Of course, in Norway,
they chant...
[ Laughter ]
And that's today's...
[ Crickets chirping ]
[ Laughing ] Which still
did better with the crew
than every other joke.
[ Laughter ]
We'll put in the crickets.
You won't hear it
over the crew laughing.
[ Laughter ]
Although it might actually
be preferable
to have a system like that
because, instead,
we have the Electoral College,
which, every four years,
anoints a handful
of swing states as kingmakers
and has awarded the presidency
to the loser of the popular
vote several times.
I mean, remember, Joe Biden got
seven million more votes
than Donald Trump,
out of a total of 158 million.
But if you flip
about 65,000 combined votes
in the right states,
Trump would win
the Electoral College,
and that's insane.
We don't do anything else
like that.
When the Steelers
score a touchdown,
it's not worth 47 points,
just because they're
from a swing state,
although that would be
very helpful, right now.
Anyway, the Electoral College
is a ticking time bomb
that is inevitably going to lead
to a major crisis of democratic
legitimacy one day.
Arguably, it already has.
It's just that Democrats,
unlike Republicans,
accept the results of elections.
And it's not even like
the Electoral College
was carefully crafted
by the founders
and designed as an integral
component of our democracy.
In fact,
they basically left it
until the last minute of the
Constitutional Convention,
then half-assed it
so they could all go home.
-1787, the founders, you know,
they go to Philadelphia,
the framers of the Constitution,
create this new document,
which has a president,
for the first time,
and they have to decide
"How are we going
to choose the president," right?
And it is the most vexing
question for the whole summer.
They fight about it
for weeks on end.
And then they come up
with this system
in the waning days
of the convention,
primarily because they were
completely exhausted.
They wanted to get
the hell out of there.
And, you know, James Madison
admits it after the fact.
He basically says,
"Yeah, you know what?
We were pretty tired
at that point."
-The founders approached
the Electoral College
with all the energy of fans
at the seventh inning
of a Mets game.
"If we leave now,
we can beat the horse traffic.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I can't find my teeth."
And it's also worth noting
that, almost immediately,
the founders realized
our system was broken
and wasn't operating
the way they intended.
They didn't think we'd devolve
into a situation
where we have to pray
that Florida
finally pulls it together,
like we're Zachary
and Taylor's mom
at the kindergarten
Christmas pageant.
"Just please behave
for one night.
Zachary!
Why would Joseph have
a light saber?!
What -- I'm sorry --
what part of the Bible, Taylor,
is a wise man
not wearing pants?!
Zachary!
Taylor!
[ Growling ]
Oh, these two!"
[ Laughter ]
The founders just wanted
to go home,
so they scratched out
a half-baked
Electoral College system
at the last minute,
then got the hell out of there.
There's a reason there's
no rap battle in "Hamilton"
about the creation
of the Electoral College,
even though I thought
my audition was very convincing.
♪ Sit back, everybody,
as I drop, a little knowledge ♪
♪ About the E to the L
to the ectoral College ♪
Shoemaker,
when you raise the roof,
you go like this,
and you're going like this.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you want me to stop? Why?
It's bad?
Yeah, but all raps start bad.
Well, agree to disagree.
You know what?
Let's have this fight later.
The Electoral College should be
abolished for the obvious reason
that, in a democracy,
everyone's vote should matter
and whoever gets the most votes
should win.
But abolishing
the Electoral College
would also have
the added benefit
of preventing future attempts
to steal the election,
through Congress or state
legislatures, or the courts,
just like the one we just saw.
The presidency would go
to whoever got the most votes
and that's it.
It would be simple.
It would be like
how a democracy works
or how any election,
anywhere, works.
In high school,
all the kids vote
for who they think
gave the funniest speech,
and then that person
is class president.
Not like the students vote
and then the prom king,
a math teacher,
and the kid with the pet iguana
get in a room
and decide if they're right.
And, if it was a simple case
and most votes win,
you wouldn't have Rudy and his
gang of cartoon characters
descending on state capitals
after one too many Jaegerbombs
at the local Houlihan's.
Democrats need to pursue major
reforms to our institutions,
to ensure that something like
this can't happen in the future,
otherwise, it will happen
in the future.
Republicans made it very clear
that, if given the chance,
they will do everything possible
to steal an election
through the courts, Congress,
or state legislatures,
and the existence
of the Electoral College
makes such an outcome
much more likely,
even if Republicans
don't have...
-A thing called standing.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.